48 Hours investigates the death of a
Georgia woman that local authorities
believe was suspicious just days after
the wife of a police officer made
allegations of abuse against her husband
he claimed she took her own life
the medical examiner ruled the death of
Amanda Perrault a suicide but the
sheriff and the district attorney
believe she was shot by her husband Seth
CBS news anchor that's Anne-Marie Green
on assignment for 48 hours has the story
it was February 3rd 2020 when Seth Perot
then a police officer for the city of
Edenton Georgia reported his 44 year old
wife Amanda had shot and killed herself
Putnam County Sheriff Howard Sills was
in charge of the investigation he said
that they were in bed and they were
arguing and then all of a sudden she
just produced the gun out of thin air
and executed herself but Sills says from
the start he wasn't buying parole's
story for one thing the crime scene
didn't look like a suicide to the
sheriff
her body is flat on her back her legs
are almost together and her arms are
tucked against her side with her hands
cut this wasn't right also of concern to
Sills was the way this Smith and Wesson
380 which belonged to Seth Perrault was
found lying next to Amanda's body with
its magazine ejected the magazine it was
near her right side
and the pistol itself
was way down here below her left foot
there's something not adding up district
attorney Wright Barksdale points to the
fact that just six days before Amanda
perold's death she had called 9-1-1 and
had her husband arrested on charges of
simple battery and Family Violence the
next day he made bond
I think he hid behind a badge and wore a
mask every day nice house law
enforcement but behind that door to that
house he was pretty abusive based in
part on the crime scene and allegations
of abuse Barksdale charged 44 year old
paroled with murder but seven months
later the medical examiner in the case
issued her report ruling Amanda perold's
death a suicide
timing of that seems very suspicious as
it does what does a husband say happen
so the husband says and he sort of
admits this was not the best
relationship that they fought a lot but
it was not an abusive relationship even
though that she even though she had
filed a claim of abuse the husband says
she lied she called 9-1-1 and she lied
and she was racked with guilt because he
was arrested it was a good possibility
he was going to lose this job and more
importantly lose custody of his young
daughter who he had just recently gotten
he says she was so guilty because she
had made that phone call to 9-1-1 that
she
killed herself now he says also that he
has proof of her State of Mind at the
time and she would leave her daughter
she felt so guilty that she was not her
daughter his daughter he was the Stepmom
okay yeah so what is his defense so the
defense is like look at the science the
medical examiner said it was a suicide
the medical examiner was grilled on the
stand she never deviated from that
conclusion but it's not just the medical
examiner's report there was barely any
blood on him we're talking about a tiny
drop of blood and almost no gunpowder
residue so you would think if you were
holding a gun you'd have a little more
than Trace gunpowder residue Trace gun
powder residue on a police officer
that's not a surprise so they say if you
look at the science the science tells a
different tale wow Speck of blood though
right tiny tiny okay yeah but tiny
matters yeah there's a doorbell video
and you've got all sorts of elements
it's a really interesting story yeah all
right Anne-Marie Green in your words
it's good to be with you guys too nice
to have you at the table and a pop of
pink color love it you can see Anne
Marie's report it's called the death of
an officer's wife on 48 hours tomorrow
night at 10 9 Central right here on CBS
in Paramount Plus